-People who are too good
at golf, they don't work.
-Oh, I see what you're saying.
-That's my philosophy.
-So I'm --
-You're constantly working
so I get it.
-[ Chuckles ] Come on.
-What's up, fellas?
I heard about that lack of lov
because of the whole
Philly football...
-Oh, man.
-...thing back there.
-He was instigating.
-Every time I come here...
-We cool. We cool.
-...it's always a problem, man
I come here.
I try to bring some love.
See, y'all supposed to be th
city of brotherly love, brother!
-We cool!
-How the Eagles doing?
[ Laughter ]
How y'all quarterback situation?
-Shut up, man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How is ours? Consistent.
-Consistently bad.
-Oh, my gosh.
-No, you know, the first tim
I ever came on this show -
They played the walk-out music
and they choose it.
The first time I came out,
it was "the space between,
talking about my teeth, man!
[ Laughter ]
-No, they thought you were
a Dave Matthews fan.
They probably thought
you were a Dave Matthews fan
-But all I got to say is
someone didn't know
that that was an April Fools
joke until today.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
♪♪ Uh, uh, uh ♪♪
He saw me, he --
-I was like, "Dude,
what happened -- I thought
you got your teeth fixed.
-No!
-Dude, I was --
-That was so funny, by the way
-Some people gullible, Jimmy
-Here he is, the one and onl
Michael Strahan!
-♪♪ Michael Strahan,
he's one of a kind ♪♪
♪♪ Sharp as a razor,
he's got his own clothing line ♪
♪♪ Michael Strahan,
he's gonna make you laugh
♪♪ Gonna tell you
'bout the NFL draft ♪♪
-Mm. I don't know --
What was the name of that --
What was the name of that song
-He just made it up on the spot.
[ Laughter ]
-You did?
-We shouldn't talk about thi
right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Know which one it is.
-Well, it's a song
about Michael Strahan.
-It's one that I wouldn't like
I guarantee you.
-No, no, it's all good things.
-It's all good things?
-Yeah. "Michael Strahan,
he's one of a kind.
Sharp as a razor,
he's got his own clothing line
Michael Strahan,
he's gonna make you laugh.
He's gonna tell you
'bout the NFL...draft."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]